it's not one of the
nicest techniques will mov say from CID
but
SM you can't just do that but when
you're doing this one two
you should
be inside just in your head your
imagination you should feel
it
so they used to say s used to vanish not
to people who watching them because they
could see what he was doing but to the
person who was on the end of it got
attack
he you'd
seen so this
I shouldn't say this but I'm in my own
environment I'm just I'm just flowing
and enjoying the
flow so when you get to that years but
when you can get that then
it's when you put stops in it it makes
it
key I don't take it off until I ready
and what I found while I took going
through my
first first my CU grades and my first
and
second I used
to it really breaks it up it's like he
spent a lot of time on one of the
seminars he spent a lot of time
saying it should peel itself
itself I just car through theing off
proc what you don't want to do is you
don't want to do it here and take it off
because now he's ahead of me and I'm
about lose my balance and he can block
me so the seniors anyone
with should come
you shouldn't be finding that you're
taking